hey everyone what's up what's up thanks
for joining me in this conversation
I am currently putting together a little
bit of content around how I think it
would be beneficial to both showcase
some of the great things that Jorn
Peterson's talking about as well as
critique some of them and try and bring
the people together try and be the glue
for the people so I want to start out by
saying that the first thing is that
Jordan and I are friends
Jordan I hosted Jordan Peterson in San
Francisco in February in a fireside chat
Jordan has done a great job at going and
inspiring people around the world to do
things like join the Future authoring
program that's such a crucial thing to
be able to want to set yourself up with
goals and go and follow through on those
goals other things like cleaning up your
own room before critiquing the world
clean yourself up first
other things like showcasing the good
and religion other things like
understanding your shadow he's been a
huge proponent of these things
especially through a psychology and his
clinical practice as professing he's
gotten a lot of experience and he's had
been able to really help catalyze a lot
of great impact through that other
things that we think are really
important that he's helped with are the
social development in children and
making sure that parents do know that
that's a really important thing to do
and of course be better than yesterday
yourself be better yourself than
yesterday not comparing other people but
to yourself yesterday so all these
things are fantastic and I think that
there a lot of people are identifying
them as great things there are certain
aspects to the nuance to all the
variables that are missing in the
conversation for example let's talk
about this one and this is one that we
had a challenge video with again
challenging Rubin and candice owens and
charlie Kirk when we were talking to
them about being more Qantas more
open-minded and having more of these
variables in conversation for example
and this is again a part of the
intellectual darkweb doing a fantastic
job of missing a couple of these links
and I want to try and be the glue here
so one of
main ones is that even though the whole
notion of picking yourself up and bring
yourself forth into the world is so
important we don't have a really solid
social fabric for unfortunate areas so
let me give you an example there's a ton
of people that are in South Chicago or
in South Boston or in Compton or all
these different areas of not only the US
but also abroad in Africa and Asia and
other places so it's across the world
there are these pockets of social fabric
where we can have better access to
technology better access to ubiquity and
energy ubiquity and food and water and
as we do that we enable people to self
actualize better we we build out the
infrastructure around people to get them
to better make value on the world better
in figure themselves out and make impact
on the world it's more difficult for
them to get out of violence and to get
out of of the limitations that when they
don't have a computer they can't program
they can't design they can't do these
things so it's up to us collectively to
both understand it's our own impact on
ourselves that we got to pick ourselves
up and go forth but also that we got to
build a better social fabric for areas
of the world to uplift everyone
collectively and so that's part of the
glue that I think is missing right there
into the conversation that is that that
needs to be had also that if we look at
it in terms of a hierarchy in terms of
people that have less socioeconomic
status at the bottom and more
socio-economic status at the top the
people at the top are just able to in
this this is this is a KA zip code
literature zip code literature is very
very well known so you're born into a
certain area that has high socioeconomic
status you're much more likely to be
able to catalyze self-actualization than
if you're in poor and you're still
looking for food you're still looking
for water you're still unsure about your
shelter that type
stuff so in this example if you're at
the top of the SES you have a higher
path forward a faster path forward at
the bottom you have a slower path
forward it's more difficult for you to
get forward so what tools and resources
can we provide to our fellow humans
because we are all human what can we do
to help catalyze their
self-actualization faster we've had the
privilege to go to places like the
Southend Tech Center in Boston where Mel
King and Susan Clem sack have
specifically focused their time on
figuring out how to put more resources
into an unfortunate underprivileged area
to empower children to get access to
sketch and scratch mi t--'s programming
language block based programming
language all these robotic parts all
these different Arduino 's and computer
parts that enable them to play with
technology and enables them to go to
colleges like Princeton from areas that
would have was much more difficult to do
so so they are able to then impact 700
elementary and middle school kids per
year they're teaching other high
schoolers how to teach younger kids so
it's this beautiful cycle so you see how
there are these things that exist that
we can really get much better doing in
order to bring everybody up at the same
time as telling them like hey it's up to
you like you yourself got to pick
yourself up at the same time so those
two things being pushed together and
it's not just underprivileged and
unfortunate and it's not just about skin
color it has it's also about rural areas
there are plenty of rural areas of like
Australia for example where it's white
kids that don't have access to the
different technologies and so what FIRST
Robotics and the Thunder Down Under
which is a team in FIRST Robotics
they've went to rural areas of Australia
where it's again it's white young kids
that don't have access to robotics and
they've provided them with access to
this technology to get them to play with
it and get them more actualized get them
the access to these tools putting them
on their tool belt so it's not about
skin colour it's it's it's about access
access to technology and access to
helping people building a stronger
social fabric for everyone on the
it okay so that's that's that and then
that's one of the ways that I think the
glue can come together stronger between
between people and I want to help be
that glue again I want to help be that
glue another thing that I think is
really important to talk about right now
is that there as as the people at the
top again of the of the hierarchy as
we're looking at the top of the
hierarchy we have a a lot of people do
have they've walls up
they've big walls up because there's a
lot of people trying to snake their way
in and do malevolent things and that's
and that's not okay to do that we got to
really stop doing that because otherwise
these walls get hiring it's hard for
benevolent people to try and get in and
collaborate with people that are that
are at the top so I think that it's it's
it's it's becoming more difficult at
times for benevolent people to try and
work together with people that are a
little bit higher up on the hierarchy to
try and collaborate you know a really
good example is whenever you try to
reach out to somebody that has a little
bit of clout typically they're not
responding to you unless you're
providing with a lot of value maybe they
see that you have high integrity or that
you're highly genuine or that you have a
high on--then tissa T all these things
then and only then will they work back
together with you so it's it's really
important to to this leads directly I
want to lead this into the next point
which is about what what's what's
happening with these stages on stages in
front of thousands two thousand three
thousands of people we usually we have
either one person giving a monologue or
we have a armchairs where people are
talking so I think that it's really
important to have interlocutors that are
able to do a good job at challenging the
person that is on stage now that doesn't
mean being rude that doesn't mean doing
things that bring that person down it is
being playful it's being kind it's
actively listening paraphrasing steel
Manning their arguments and then saying
hey what about this aspect to it what if
we add that to it what if I challenge
you a bit here and nudge you a bit what
are your thoughts on that so I think
it's really important to have an
interlocutor on stage rather than a
monologue a lot of the time and I think
it's important for for for us to figure
out who are these people that are trying
to come up and make these challenges why
are they trying to make them to be the
glue are they trying to do something
else so that then okay here's here's
something else to keep in mind that
careers are important and kids are
important and I think this is something
that Jordan addresses a lot which is
that having kids is so important don't
miss your window to have kids they're
really playful they're fun it's a great
opportunity and mold kids into the world
I totally agree that that's an important
aspect of life at the same time I think
men and women equally even women can
find self-actualization and meaning in
life by impacting the world in ways that
are not having kids by starting
companies that that bring lots of value
to the world by having missions and
purposes that do things like make the
world a better place for civilizations
to come you don't need to do that
directly through a child you can do that
through a project that you found and
that you work on so I just want to make
that clear that it's totally possible to
do it through a project as well and not
just through children so keep that
totally open and then that being
eccentric is crucial there's so much
pressure on us now to conform and fit
into a certain cycle of work you fit
into a regiment of eight hours of sleep
eight hours of work eight hours of play
you sleep from midnight until 8:00 a.m.
we all do the certain things that
everybody else does and that's actually
creating there are certain aspects to
that that are right like for sure try
and get eight hours of sleep every
single night it's important why we sleep
really important but also figure out
what works for you to build your mission
and your impact in the world if you need
to if you need to stay up a little bit
later and wake up a little bit later a
couple days then then do that so that
you
can focus be eccentric be different it's
not just about sleep it's about your
behavior in the outside world it's not
about going and running around on the
streets naked and yelling really loudly
to be different but it's more things
like when you see everybody at an event
that's having small talk try and walk up
to people and ask them really deep
questions really quickly what are you
passionate about what do you care about
what are your values and just try and
get deep into people as quickly as
possible to figure out who are these
people that you want to surround
yourself with that you want to make
connections with quickly so be the black
sheep go the way that other people
aren't going more often be eccentric
don't follow that that path that
everybody follows all the time okay
sometimes go the other path now this is
an important challenge I have tried
talking to Jordan about this I haven't
gotten an answer but in rule number
eight tell the truth or at least don't
lie one thing that I'd like to challenge
that with is what if you are hiding Jews
in your house during World War two then
what and you have the Nazis come to your
door and they say are you hiding Jews
and then do you do you tell the truth or
do you lie let that sink in for a moment
so what do we do in that case so I just
want to bring these questions up again
as an interlocutor distt trying to
challenge just trying to play and see
what the what the answers are to these
to these interestingly nuanced and
multivariate questions and we're staying
at quantum as' that's so important we're
trying to express love and empathy for
all people in all perspectives but also
to figure out how to bring the glue
together and move forward as one and not
shatter us apart with the polarization
that's currently existing so we'd like
to help out with that maybe there's some
sort of layer of scientific objective
truth even though religion does bring us
a lot of that as Jordan says a lot of
this morality in this actualization that
we have soda science science tells us
that the world that the earth orbits the
star it tells us about the molecular
composition of water tells us about our
heart beating about a hundred thousand
times a day all these things maybe we
can build some foundational objective
layers of true
that we can teach children and progress
forward as a planet with together so
this direct message again just to remind
you Jordan and I are friends he's done a
great job inspiring people around the
world and I want to make that very clear
that I just want to see aspects of him
and the intellectual darkweb be slightly
more nuanced more quantum assult i
variate that there are people like me
and other people that want to add a
little bit of challenges to it maybe to
be the glue that loops the people
together that are currently polarized
how can we bring them together and move
forward that's a lot of what I care
about I really appreciate you tuning in
to listen to this direct message about
what's going on in the world and
especially regards to what's going on
Jordan Peterson and the intellectual
dark web and the things that that I can
hopefully help us with so join me in
wanting to do that join us with this
project simulation as we ask really
thought-provoking questions to people as
we highlight leaders across science and
entrepreneurship and and huge thank you
again and if you had a good time with
this video please give it a share give
the video a share and give a comment
below with your thoughts
give us subscribe join us in the
movement and we'd love to hear your
thoughts and and move forward together
let's get it
tweet at tweet the video at at Jordan
and add a couple of the other
intellectual dark web folks eric
weinstein dave rubin canta Solon's get
it out there too some of them Joe Rogan
let's see if we can if we can get them
involved in this conversation and stay
very a quantum as' multi very playful
but also looking forward and trying to
build a better world together so thank
you very much really appreciate it and
I've also had the pleasure of having
guys sang stock here throughout this
guy's a very close friend of mine the
founder of the circling Institute and he
has been crucial in wanting to bring
forth really beautiful strategies for
authenticity and transform
in the world and so I would like to open
it up to see if guy has anything that
was that he thought had an impact there
was an interlocutor here what did you
think about the direct message and were
there things that you think that you
could move me on that you can challenge
me on as well I want to become clear
about what I'm I'm actually what I'm
actually hearing you correctly yeah so
one of the last things you said that
that your intention here is to be that
the the glue right to to is that to
bring more people into the conversation
yeah okay cool
now how you're doing that is through
challenge you're challenging some of his
ideas and what I really like about what
you said is that you're doing it in a
way such that you're respecting the
human being
you're not like assuming the human being
is some way but you're basically saying
like you're respecting the human being
that they have a right to think what
they think and and that you
fundamentally say that that's good and
so you're making the distinction between
the human being and what they say and
their ideas and your you're laying that
out that is like I think that's
essential and I think that's the one of
the biggest things missing yeah but what
do you make of this connection between
bringing people together by challenging
them well how does that what's that how
does that work yeah I'm happy that you
brought that first point up which was
that humans and then their ideas yeah
and so of respecting all seven and half
billion humans just for being human and
then whatever their ideas are on top of
that how can you steal man conversations
to help build a better world together
not straw man not manipulate people but
have really strong thought-provoking
conversations now in the bringing people
together and being the glue it's like a
collaboration of challenging so it's
like when when a tennis ball is hit your
way you add your own thoughts to the
tennis ball and hit it back in a way
that add some spin and then the other
person receives that tennis ball that
might have a little bit more spin so
it's more difficult for them to hit back
but it's much easier it's much better
for the world
to have a tennis ball be hit over that
has some spin on it that's harder to hit
back than it is to just hit up a volley
and make it super easy for them to hit
the tennis ball back that doesn't make
for interesting conversation when you
have volleys going back and forth people
are like yeah we've heard all of this
stuff but when you hit the ball back
with some spin on it make it a little
bit more difficult for that for the
person sitting in the armchair for the
cross from you to hit it back it's more
unique it's more novel so it's a
collaboration 'el Talon geing it's a
playful challenging it's a it's a
friendly challenge
it's a progressing challenge one that's
focused on societal prospering okay so
so if you were to bring up a difference
all right and we did if we actually had
the glue or if I were to bring up a
difference and what what are you
supposed to do with that difference or
that spin like why is it good to have
the spin like is it is it like is it so
that you can think the thoughts I'm
thinking is it so you can see your own
thoughts as they are what's the for you
what's the what's important about that
so when you hit the ball back to me with
some spin yeah then why is that good for
the conversation yeah so when you hit it
back with the spin on it I am then
usually introduced to something that is
more novel yeah and so when I'm
introduced to something that's more
novel it makes me think in a way that I
might not have thought before and then
it kind of gets me to it gets me to
manifest some sort of a perspective that
I might not have thought before and if
that's happening live on camera or live
in an audience that's really good way
for people to be like hmm I don't know
that's a really good point and for
people to say things like I don't know
that's a sign of vulnerability that's a
sign of totally being okay with not
knowing yeah and that's a very beautiful
thing yeah and we can come up with a
slight thought about you know that would
be like kind of like you know almost
like whiffing on the tennis ball and
being like hey it's totally okay that I
whipped on that tennis ball that had a
lot of spin on it because it's a really
difficult question to answer
yeah when we sit here on the show and we
ask people about what do we
about globalization what do we do about
wealth inequality how do we progress
together as a civilization it's really
it's a really difficult question the
answer has trillions variable so it's um
it's one that it's difficult to hit back
so that novelty that you add spin if I
can form something about it saying I
don't know but here's something that I
think might help us together right then
that's so valuable way more valuable
than ivali is yeah other person so so I
think what I'm hearing you say is that
basically if we're if we have
conversations where I'm not I'm like I'm
not trying to be right right but I'm
trying to converse in other words yeah
like a lot of times I noticed enough
like I don't I find out what I think
through finding out what I end up saying
in the conversation so a lot of times I
start to articulate my ideas in the act
of the conversation yeah and sometimes
that's like really good news but
sometimes that's like oh whoa I didn't
even think of that
so there's this element I just want to
bring in of like well why don't people
do that already and I think it actually
it goes back to what I heard jordan
peterson say one time he's like when you
when you truly learn something new if
it's really if it's really you're really
learning something new it means that you
need to unlearn something else the
process of learning something new is the
also the process of unlearning something
else and our biases right our are our
well cherished ideas we get irritated
when they're challenged right because we
step on top of our presuppositions yes
so like I just want to say that like it
takes a kind of courage to step into a
forum in which I'm voluntarily open to
die in a certain way I'm open to like
let go of an idea even some of my vote
was precious ideas and that's I think
just that the demonstration of that
courage is already a message yes I love
that the the true beauty of saying that
what I had as an idea before actually
has fault to it and I want to push that
idea to the side now I want to move
forward with this other idea and being
totally evil
durable and open about it to the public
and saying things like hey I actually
did think this way it was wrong I've
moved I've moved on we've seen actually
a decent amount of that in the news
nowadays is people saying that yeah I
used to think that I think this now I
think it's better not for these reasons
and being totally open vulnerable and
loving in that transition and then you
asked about this importance of having an
outstanding conversation knowing how to
converse with people and this has been
something that we talked to Jordan about
when he was here in San Francisco is the
art of an outstanding conversation how
to actually do this this I think boils
down to a couple things like you said
it's about the dialogue and the
conversing first and foremost it's not
about trying to win you are not trying
to win it's about the conversation it's
about the dialogue then when there is
there are certain aspects to that like
these objective things like your heart
is the one thing that's beating and
keeping you alive and if someone's like
no it's not then it's like hey okay
let's revisit this let's figure out how
to help how to help you figure this out
now for example with with these main
principles that we need to keep in mind
to have a great conversation we need to
stay open-minded
we need to be an active listener we need
to listen more than we talk we need to
ask really good questions and if we feel
the person's diverging and going on a
tangent just ask them hey can you pause
I just want to bring us back quick so
there's all these different strategies
that you can do also having a lot of
nuance and conversation covering all the
variables political issues are not
binary issues science is binary like
gravity existing on the face of the
earth at a certain
meters-per-second-square pulldown so
that is binary politics is not so all
these different layers and nuance
totally being a quantum Estill and
loving and caring and open-minded as you
converse with them so that's this art of
outstanding conversation and trying to
bring that to more people around the
world is something so important
especially as we
design civilization build our future
together the other thing I heard you say
so much I could say about that my own
experience but I also want to talk about
what you talked about I think it licit
ly you talked about with the here are
key yeah right the competence here are
key used to be called the dominance
hierarchy I think what I basically heard
you say is that the people at the top
right have a responsibility to to make
sure that the people at the bottom are
have have equal opportunity basically
and so where your attention what I heard
you say is like where your attention
goes is like if somebody's at the top
and they have walls around them and
they're not open to like if they're not
open to like other ideas or something
like that that seem to presuppose the
other side of that they're not going to
necessarily be in service of the bottom
of the hierarchy and it does seem to be
like a natural what natural hierarchies
do are there so that the most amount of
competence right at the top can then
look at the bottom and then figure out
how to how do we get the bottom to have
the most opportunity yes right yes your
your I'm happy that you brought this
back up because it awakened another
thought in me that we should communicate
which is that the the the current the
current state of of what exists in human
socioeconomic status sorting by a
hierarchy is now a period of a couple
million years of evolution especially
the last couple hundred thousand and
last thousand especially as money has
come into our lives and we figured out
the people at the top have to access to
the most technology the most the most
highest shelters highest foods highest
these things Health Care's etc so so
then is it their responsibility to look
down and figure it out being the most
competent and try and lift everybody up
this is a very very difficult question
evolution actually has been a insane
trajectory that has bifurcated trifer
cated made genetic variations and along
the way has usually has the top lobster
the top human winning in the cases
always getting the best the top keeps
getting the best the top keeps getting
the best keeps getting the best so are
we gonna continue with this trajectory
of the top getting the best getting the
best and then the bottom kind of kind of
coming up but also dying at the same
time coming up and dying until there's a
speciation or until or until something
some sort of a split potentially occurs
between the wealth or will we figure out
how to take the competence at the top
and figure out how to uplift everyone
collectively more more strongly overtime
here's the thing I want to kind of I
want to cut into a little bit with that
so when you say lift up so we're looking
like I'm at the top of the Heric right
I'm looking down in like I want to
create opportunities for them to come up
is it where is the responsibility of the
person at the top is it is it to lift up
or is it to give the opportunity for
them or the mean such that if they want
to be lifted up they can lift up like
where does the where does the lifting up
happen yeah that's the complicated
question funneling money down handouts
figuring out how to do things like the
south end Tech Center with providing
computers and resources for kids to come
in and really I think it inspired by
seems to be doing pretty good right um
kids are getting into great colleges
they're able to pursue careers that are
really impactful and meaningful so
that's really interesting so I tend I
tend towards to gravitate towards that
and then I'm furthermore how do we make
that better I don't know I would love to
figure out how to make that better so I
think first of all I just like as you're
talking I was like you know what I just
I feel a sense of security just in the
fact that we're asking the question yeah
right like I think that's probably the
biggest biggest thing is to be
asking the question because the hero RP
is a hierarchy because we haven't
completed it yet like otherwise there
wouldn't be a here RP if you're more
going somewhere right so there's we're
on our way to something that seems to
presuppose a hero key or a Talos or a a
purpose that we're constantly just
finding out even what that is right so
there's a where I personally had a years
ago had an experience of a real question
that just spontaneously happened for me
is I used to I used to live over on Bay
and Taylor in in San Francisco and I
moved here to go to art school and I
went to the San Francisco Art Institute
which is this like I'm still in debt
from that thing it's like this really
intense art school that it's a linked up
20 grand back that a year to go through
and my parents didn't have any money I
didn't come from a whole bunch of money
and I figured out how to get myself in
there and like work it out and pay for
it and all that kind of stuff and I'm
sitting on I'm sitting I'm sitting
outside my window looking across the
street which was back then it was the
bay the the Bay Street projects and I'm
looking down and I'm looking at a group
of like the drug dealers that are you
know selling crack and stuff right were
they you know the cars come down I
started figuring about this and I was
like you know what I bet in terms of
opportunity I would I would imagine like
a nice - I don't actually literally know
if this is true I'm just speculating but
I was thinking about if one of them
wanted to go and do what I was doing I
bet they actually have more
opportunities than I do like government
funding you know subsidizing all those
kinds of things and I probably have is
like less money than they do right and
I'm going there what is the difference
between that like what is the difference
that made that difference where they
actually have more opportunity than I do
speculatively what is the difference
between me like moving in that direction
and taking up and not that's a big
question what do you think that it as
you look out the window and you see
people
dealing drugs there's a tendency for me
to want to think that like what led them
to that point and then what
opportunities do they have now their
opportunities are very vast like you
described there are actually a lot of
opportunities there's got to figure out
how to fit themselves into those
opportunities
whereas with what you were doing you
were already going down a track your
opportunities already became narrowed
because you went down a track and now
they're gonna blossom out again as you
finished that track and figure out where
to go with them so opportunity is a very
interesting thing we do not talk about
equal outcome we talk about equal
opportunity and the importance of that
and so figuring out how to do that for
people that are both deciding to go
through school that are not going
through school for people that are in
the low economic brackets versus to hire
how do we make that happen moving
forward one of the most challenging
questions of our lifetime in the next
hundred years is how do we work together
across all the socio-economic statuses
to move forward together or will there
be a split and so that kind of a
question is one that I think let's let's
end the conversation with let's
hopefully other people will want to will
want to share that conversation that
aspect of the conversation especially
everyone again guy thank you for - thank
you for coming and and helping me out
here I appreciate it thank you Ron
Vargas are producing partner for doing
this we really appreciate everyone for
tuning in if you guys again if you had a
good time thinking about some of the
things that we've been talking about
share the content with other people
subscribe join us comment below with
your thoughts and we'd love to hear them
and let's get more of this
thought-provoking discourse going on
let's bring let's be the glue of
bringing people together through this
collaboration these challenging thoughts
around each other and much love thank
you everyone